hey guys it's Justine and if you haven't
heard Apple has announced a new version
of Mac OS called Mac OS Sonoma it's
coming to an Apple computer near you
this fall but the public beta recently
went live so here we are we're gonna
check it out right now now there's a lot
of new stuff Safari has new browsing and
privacy features messages has some good
upgrades and there's some crazy new
screensavers there's a high performance
mode for screen sharing as well as
better experiences for notes and PDFs
but what's probably most exciting are
the new features for widgets video
conferencing and gaming we're going to
go over all of that stuff in this video
so be sure to hit the like button and
subscribe if you like breadsticks
because all I can think about is the
Olive Garden and that's where that's
where I think I'm going to be ordering
food from right now
anyway moving on first let's check out
these new
for just
first of all the log
and redesign with the date and display
up on top so it kind of feels like your
iPhone lock screen now so you can see
that they've moved the login experience
down to the bottom of the screen and
this clears the frame to feature
whatever screen saver or wallpaper that
you have so these are the new screen
savers they're actually slow motion
videos of imagery from different places
around the world and then when you log
in the video just seamlessly settles
into the desktop wallpaper it's pretty
cool I think I might stick with this
Hawaii one now Safari has now introduced
profiles so you can separate your
browsing into different topics you could
have one profile for work one for
browsing or one for gaming or even one
for planning a trip now I really like
this because your profiles will have
separate history cookies extensions and
favorites and everything will go across
all of your devices so you'll see I have
my two different profiles that I have
here so I've got my home and my work so
right now when you are viewing Safari
you can tell where you're at in your
profile so right here we have work and
you can designate different colors so
you'll easily be able to tell which
profile you're in this is pretty cool
now in Sonoma you can also use Safari to
make web apps so with this you can add
your favorite websites right into the
dock and when you launch one it's more
of an app-like experience with a
simplified toolbar I'm a big fan of this
feature now messages we covered a little
bit in my iOS 17 video so if you haven't
seen that yet make sure to go check it
out after this one but we're going to
take a look at messages here because I
actually really use messages on my Mac a
lot so what's really cool is all of the
live stickers that you make on your
iPhone or your iPad you can use here on
the Mac so this gives you the same
little pop-up feature so if I click into
stickers you'll see the ones that I made
and here we are we're going to send that
to my sister Jenna I think she'll enjoy
it what's this one
there we go we sent her two stickers
love to see it now another messages
feature that I really like is ketchup so
now you can easily jump to the top of
your unread messages in group chats Now
new in screen sharing there's a new high
performance mode that uses the media
engine and apple silicon to make remote
access super responsive with low latency
audio and high frame rate this is a
professional level workflow so if you're
a Creator or a video editor you can now
access your content from anywhere and
you can even use Final Cut Pro or
resolve to edit remotely with ultra high
definition and this will give you a
seamless workflow from wherever you are
this of course will require a pretty
fast internet connection and I'm pretty
excited because I do have two gig up two
gig down so this could be my future like
I definitely could see making a whole
video about this and incorporating some
of this into my remote workflows now in
notes and PDF there is a new experience
for reading PDFs right inside of notes
you can just flip through the pages and
you can preview multiple PDFs inside the
same notes and then when you're ready
you can continue working on your note in
Pages just by going into the share menu
all right so now on to the features that
we all want to know about you can now
interact with widgets in Macos Sonoma
and also place them right on the desktop
you can even use widgets from your
iPhone on your Mac and vice versa you
can actually interact with these widgets
and they have the same larger widget
design that we have seen with the iPad
OS I mean this looks so slick now when
you want to add a new widget you just go
into the newly redesigned library and
you can browse through your available
widgets it's so nice these widgets will
automatically adapt to your desktop The
Tint will change based off your
background wallpaper and when you see
them next to the files the system will
automatically shift stuff around and
make room on your desktop so files and
stacks wrap around the widgets adapting
to your available space another thing
that I'm very excited about in the new
Mac OS are the upgrades in video
conferencing I'm unfortunately I mean
it's just a part of life at this point I
do quite a few of conference calls every
week so these updates are pretty
exciting there's now some system-wide
improvements to make video calls more
functional and engaging so now when
you're sharing your screen you can
choose the new presenter overlay effect
and this will superimpose you over
whatever content you're showing this is
great because if you're on a big call
and someone is presenting you might not
always know who is speaking if you can't
see them so this lets you see the
content and the person at the same time
there's also now some animated reactions
for video calls as well so without
interrupting you can send a heart or a
thumbs up just by doing some hand
gestures now I like this because a lot
of time on Twitter spaces I love to feel
like I'm interacting and giving kind of
like a little heart or a little shout
out here and it's represented by a
digital graphic so the fact that you can
now kind of do this on video calls I'm
so excited I do feel like these have
taken it to a whole other level because
it basically is a whole animated screen
but I love it and now the moment that
you've all been waiting for or maybe I'm
the only one that's waiting for it
because I just want to play video games
on my Mac Mac OS Sonoma now has a
dedicated game mode that will optimize
your Mac for high performance gaming
experience so this basically gives games
the highest priority on the CPU and GPU
and gives less bandwidth to your
background tasks enabling smooth
consistent frame rates they've also
drastically lowered the latency when
gaming with airpods which I'm pretty
excited about and they lower the input
latency for game controllers by doubling
the Bluetooth sampling rate so if you've
ever played any video games before on
wireless devices like a controller or
Bluetooth headsets the more noticeable
that lag is the less immersive your
gaming experience is now this will work
with any game and they're adding a bunch
of new and upcoming ones as well so that
my friends is some of the top features
in Mac OS Sonoma I'm definitely excited
to try this out I know when most of
these os's come out I do tend to wait a
few months because I want to make sure
that all of my editing plugins are
updated and if I'm editing and I don't
have them and they're not updated I
usually do wait a little while but man
it's been so fun testing this out and I
can't wait to actually use it